you look great I I am great in a in an
average sort of way yeah but you've
cornered the market in that an average
yes yeah I fired to do that I've got
average yeah okay so this is the oldest
golf trophy well in the sport I love the
major of the majors yes okay yeah it is
value said the Scottish Open trophy yeah
it's older than this it is it's about 40
years older and unfortunately it hasn't
been seen since 1986 but you you somehow
lost it when you wanted in 1986 you won
the Scottish Open and they gave you a
trophy yeah they did how do you lose
this Daanish open well if I knew how I'd
lost and I probably would know where it
is yeah there was a concert and Glasgow
that night that I went to and the next
48 hours are lost in the swirling mists
of time not sure what happened there but
I woke up in the ferns to the left of
the 16th tee at Gleneagles like a dead
red stag and the trophy was missing was
anybody babysitting you back then yeah
there were I'd several babysitter's but
I think Child Protective Services were
called and they were all carted off to
various institutions leaving me on my
own but it's that part of a caddies job
keeping an eye on you
well then some no no it was quite the
other way around
and those days with me I my caddies
I had one rodney Willer who was the
single most useless human being in the
northern hemisphere at any given moment
I'll tell you one exchange that I had
with Rodney would sort of typifies who
he was we were planning to turn on
called the car care international in
Leeds and it was the sleet was coming
down as we were teeing off on the first
and I'm hiding behind the umbrella and
praying that it's gonna be a lull in the
squall whatever my name is an Einstein
fine I got my glove on and when I run
out you know and I've tee the ball up
and straight into this sleeve
when do you know coming down and I hit
my t-shot and I look up and just as I
look up a big piece of you know frozen
rain hits me in the eye so I'm stumbling
around and I get in behind the umbrella
you know and said where'd that go Rodney
he looks at me and he says where'd what
go yeah that's not what you want from
akattak no but he was entertaining did
they did they your caddy celebrate with
you yo yes yeah so when you and you
would go out and have fun back when you
did drink the Caddy would cuz normally
caddies are their own little world like
they're of their own little rockstars
yeah it's a different scene today
they're very much more I mean they make
a lot more money and they're a lot more
professional they're not the sort of
hedge dwellers that they used to be the
caddies back and and you know before
when I played as well I mean there's a
they're the lifeblood of the game they
really are I got a lot of stories man
yeah one that when you go to Scotland or
Ireland you know and play the club
counties that are around and they're
lifers their generational the Byrne
family from Port marnik you know have
been caddies for generations and it just
gets handed done and you know the kind
of behavior the know if that ball was
wrapped in big and lossy wouldn't find
it you know but when you play in Europe
especially in Ireland or Scotland it's
amazing that you had these caddies who
can find your ball oh yeah and it could
be in like thick thick stuff but somehow
they find it over there
they also gamble on you yes like I got
traded one time on the first tee yeah
that's it guys all my practice we and
all of a sudden he changes bags and I
said what happened he said you just got
traded yeah yeah and I was with a pro
I'm group you know I'm their Pro on the
tee and I remember a caddy you know
watching one of the amateurs make a
practice swing and he said is that this
one you're going to use some died in
there he's David Feherty who's joining
us and part of the Open Championship
coverage on NBC that this first time
you've covered the open isn't it
is yeah I'm really looking forward to it
and it's at Royal Troon where if it
hadn't been for five bastards that
played better than I did I would have
won it and in 1989 I finished sixth and
I won the Tooting back Cup which is not
yeah the Tooting Bec Cup is for the the
leading home player and the Open
Championship you know from the British
Isles if you're from and it's it's not a
cup it's a it's a medal that's about
that size you know
yeah the turnings 90 yeah the Tooting
Bec Cup who wanted that year I played
with Calcavecchia in the last round and
he wanted in a playoff with Norman and
Wayne Grady yeah most talented player
you ever played with the most talented
well Tiger Woods and I didn't play with
him me I played with a couple exhibition
matches with him you know but what about
competitive rounds competitive runs
where you sort of went I'm not in this
guy's league oh I shouldn't be in this
twosome
oh yeah well he was well past his
sell-by date but the most impressive
player I ever saw I think was late
Trevino
just someone who hit the ball in the
middle of the clubface and he was
probably in his 50s when I played with
him well late 40s maybe and it was just
it was a it was he transcended the game
he hit the ball you know so beautifully
out of the middle and and so many shapes
you know and and it was talking on his
downswing he was yeah yeah it just it
was amazing to be around do you care
what is a conversation that you have
when you're competing with somebody yeah
I like I see Spieth and Rory walking I
think are they talking about golf they
talk about shots conditions quite often
they're gonna be talking about other
sports you know if the NBA championships
or you know what's going on at the same
time you know there with social media
and it was a microphone and a camera
everywhere they're great characters out
there but they you know they can't
afford to be great characters on the
golf course you know anymore because
you know their level to get skewered for
it it's it's sad in a way you know
because it takes away a lot of the color
from the game I know that we know what
I'm out there you know I they'll be
telling jokes
well you lighten the mood when you're
cub you're following the leaders yeah I
mean you certainly did that with Tiger
yeah tiger and I had fun out there we
did especially in the you know the early
years but its but he was so good even
your distractions weren't distractions
well no no but didn't you have like a
fart bag or something or get a like
something that noises that you would
make yeah but I would think Tiger gets
so locked in that why why did he allow
you to add levity well I I think he
would allow anyone to add levity it
wasn't specifically because it was me he
is just I mean Jack Nicklaus is the same
that you know they don't suffer fools
gladly
but what jacket will allowed you to do
something like that yeah yeah that's you
Jack impersonation there yeah yeah sure
yeah go ahead I want to ask you about
Dustin Johnson Oakmont the whole
controversy there yeah and the role that
social media now plays and everybody
wants to be a rules official yeah yeah
and I don't know if that played a role
in Dustin Johnson or not but we'll
continue with David Feherty also are you
a soccer fan I well I was and I kind of
am again not with the way that you know
soccer has come so popular in this
country it's it's great to see but
Northern Ireland they actually had a
decent showing I think in the yes yeah
did you were you a George best fan Mona
oh of course
absolutely I mean George best didn't get
true cheated so he didn't what get
cheated no living in life no he didn't
you know it was asked you know because
he was the fifth Beatle is what they
called him you know in that era and and
he he said he that he spent most of his
money on alcohol women and fast cars and
the rest he just squandered
yeah I will continue with David FATA to
brought in the Claret Jug NBC will carry
the British Open this year also David is
uh is going to the Olympics yeah I'm
just hope they don't drug test
announcers I'm going with you by the way
Oh excellent yes yes yeah I'm gonna be
there as well alright yeah I'm kind of a
big deal at NBC hmm I think yeah but you
didn't know I was going to the Olympics
you want like to mean I'm still not sure
if I'm going no you are going it says
right here this piece of paper you gave
me said yes that you're actually gonna
be contributing to Bob Costas I know
yeah you get to sit next to Bob I'm
excited but it's gonna be great and
you're on Fallon in July yep
have you ever been on Fallon before well
I was to be on Fallon tonight but I got
bumped
so they got a they have a much more
important guest tonight Ben Simmons that
would be it
yeah wait you got bumped for Ben Simmons
I'm not sure whether it was ban or I
think you know they were maybe trying to
find someone you know that I could play
with a little better I mean the last
time I was on Leno I licked Howie
Mandel's head we've all done that well
yeah yeah yeah I turned the green room
into the brown room yeah all right we'll
continue I see I didn't even ask a
follow-up question that we'll talk about
Tigers dead season a few things talked
about including the US Open with Dustin
Johnson will continue with David Feherty
right after this the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience